قال مسؤول امريكي رفيع من الولايات
المتحده رصدت منطاد تجسس صني وقال اراد
الامريكيا وتقوم بتتبعه منذ دخوله الى
الاجواي الجويه الامريكيه قبل ايام واضاف
المسؤول في احاطه عبر الهاتف ان الهدف من
المنطاد هو التجسس ومساره يمر وعبر عدد من
المواقع الحساسه لكنه اشار الى ان تاثيره
محدود في جمع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه كما
ذكر ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن استفسر
عن خيارات عسكريه لاسقاط المنقاد بمجرد
اطلاعه على الامر لكن وزير الدفاع
ورئيس هيئه الاركان المشتركه الجنرال مارك
ميلي او صايا بعدم اتخاذ اجراء عسكري بسبب
الخطر المحتمل لحطام المنطاد في حال تم
اسقاطه في مناطق ماهوله وقل المسؤول
الامريكي والرفيعون الولايات في المتحده
قد اخطرت اغلب او كل الول
المسؤولين الصينيين اخترت المسؤولين
الصينيين بماذا خطوره الموقف على نحو عاجل
مشيرا الى ان هذه ليست المره الاولى التي
يتم فيها رصد منطاد تجسس اجنبي فوق
الاراضي الامريكيه
محمد الاحمد مراسلون في واشنطن ضموا الي
الان محمد هل من تفاصيل اكثر عن هذا
التطور الجديد
نعم مسؤول في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
لبنتاغون عقد احاطه عبر الهاتف قبل قليل
واشار الى ان الولايات المتحده رصدت هذا
المنطاد الذي يعتقد انه منطاد صيني وبان
السلطات الامريكيه تتبع مساره منذ دخوله
الى الاجواء الامريكيه قبل عده ايام
المسؤول اشار الى ان الهدف من هذا المنقاد
على ما يبدو هو
للتجسس وبانه يمر عبر مواقع حساسه لكنه
اشار في الوقت نفسه الى ان تاثير هذا
المنطاد في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه يبقى محدود مسؤول امريكي
وفق شبكه الام بي سي اشار الى ان المنطاد
يحلق حاليا على مرتفعات عاليه فوق ولايه
مونتانا وهي محاديه
لكندا لكنه لم يفصح عن المكان المحدد لهذا
المنطار واشرت في نفس الوقت الى انه لا
يوجد تاثير على حركه الملاحه الجويه
المدنيه بسبب هذا المنطاد بالرغم من ان
الام بي سي اشارت الى توقف بعض انشطه
الطيران العسكري في
مونتانا نتيجه
للاكتشاف هذا المنطاد الصيني الرئيس جو
بايدن بحسب المسؤول في البنتاجون طلب
خيارات للتعامل مع المنطاد واسقاطه كان
هناك بحسب شبكه الام بي سي اجتماع يوم
الاربعاء في القاده العسكريين وتم تدارس
بعض الخيارات التي تم تقديمها الى الرئيس
بايدن لكن بحسب الشبكه فان القاده
العسكريون نصحوا بعدم اسقاطه سواء عن طريق
الجو او بوسائل اخرى وذلك لاحتمال سقوط
حطام هذا المنطاد على المناطق الماهوله في
نفس الوقت السلطات الامريكيه يبدو انها
تواصلت مع الجانب الصيني
سواء في بيتين او هنا في واشنطن من اجل
النقل المخاوف الامريكيه وبعض وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه في الواقع وبعض
التقارير الامريكيه تتحدث عن استدعاء
القائم باعمال السفير الصيني هنا في
واشنطن من طرف وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
للتعبير عن القلق بشان وجود منطاد تجسس
صيني فوق المجال الجوي الامريكي بحسب بعض
المسؤولين الامريكيين فان مثل هذه الانشطه
ليست خارجه عن المالوف لكن يعتقد ان
الايام التي قطع قضاها هذا المنطاد فوق
الاراضي الامريكيه اكبر بكثير مقارنه مع
محاولات سابقه لكن هذا التطور ياتي في
الواقع محمد في وقت يوجد في توتر كبير بين
الجانبين خاصه ان الكشف عن هذا المنطاد
ياتي بعد زياره مهمه لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي الى الفلبين والاعلان عن توسيع
الوجود العسكري الامريكي هناك في اطار
الاستجابه والرد على التهديدات الصينيه
ياتي ايضا بعد سلسله من
التحالفات والاتفاقيات بين الولايات
المتحده وبعض الدول المحاديه للصين
كاليابان وايضا ياتي الكشف عن هذا التطور
قبيل زياره مرتقبه لوزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى الصين في مطلع او بعد ايام
عمليا وهي زياره
يتوقع ان تتناول جميع اوجه الخلاف
والملفات العالقه بين الجانبين لكن الكشف
عن هذا المنطاد يمكن ان يكون ايضا في ضمن
القضايا التي قد تطرحها الولايات الوزير
الخارجي الامريكي بالتحديث ياما ان
الانشطه التجسس الصينيه هي مساله بالغه
يعني الحساسيه
من الجانب الامريكي منذ عده سنوات محمد
اذا مثلما ذكرت هذا تطور هو غيظ من فيض
توتر كبير بين الجانبين محمد الاحمد مراسل
الجزيره في واشنطن شكرا جزيلا